like cuz men have like an innate gut
feeling about stuff women we just our
emotions take us God knows wherever but
men have an innate like I don't know
Spidey senses about things but women
kind of manipulate them and try to get
them to not listen to their gut that is
the that is the biggest that is the
cannot do that as a guy because look now
he's conditioned into thinking that he
should have opened up to Tupac more that
this behavior is okay people that think
of being dramatic when I say marriage
can be a prison and a death sentence for
men but a lot of times men not having
Authority in their own household is a
prison for them